[Music]
[Applause]
hey what's going on hot ones fans I'm
Sean Evans and it is time for the NBA
draft of hot sauces the selection Sunday
of scovilles the day when hot sauce
maker dreams and celebrity nightmares
collide in a beautiful symphony of spice
this is the hot ones season nine hot
sauce reveal brought to you by Comedy
Central South Side a very funny comedy
about my hometown of Chicago for those
who are new to the game this is where we
wiped a table clean and unveil the new
sauces that will be smoking out
celebrities on the next season of hot
ones and for season 9 it's all about
that new new across the board all six of
our new hot sauces are from makers who
have never before been featured on hot
ones many of them hotter than their
predecessors from the labels to the
flavors to the pepper varieties it is
shake up City here in season nine but
one place where we stay constant is in
the leadoff spot with the classic the
sauce that makes l'bri say oh wow this
is delicious I'm so glad I agreed to eat
these wings on the internet before the
scoville body blows begin the classic at
the number one spot it stays and then
moving down the line at the number two
spot is a cheeky little number called
sauce bay out of Spring Lake New Jersey
for all you goop heads I've been getting
into golden lattes lately this is the
sauce for you the beautiful color comes
from a healthy hit of turmeric which
gives it this pleasantly bitter earthy
profile which is then rounded out with
sweet pineapple and a nice Tang of white
vinegar
hey Gwyneth Paltrow come on the show you
big goop in the three-spot say hello to
your new best friend Shaquanda this
island style hot sauce is made in Bed
Stuy
but the scotch bonnet and habanero
driven heat is straight out of Barbados
fun fact the name Shaquanda comes from
the maker Andre Springer's drag queen
alter-ego I put my name into a drag
queen name generator' and it came back
vodka Slim's at number four we had just
south of Oakland to Hayward California
to scoop up our cleanup hitter this cute
little pup lucky dog year of the dog
shoutout to Ruggles the official pup of
hot ones and shout out to the Southeast
Asian inspired spice delivered with a
mix of red Thai chilies lime roasted
garlic pineapple and toasted sesame with
brings us to the Midway mark of our hike
up Mount Scovel your old friend Lowe's
calientes Season 9 is cranked in the
heat all summer so you know we had to
keep the sauce of summer and then moving
on to the back half of the lineup in at
number six we're up in the ante with
Hellfire Detroit repping the Motor City
with a sauce that's as straightforward
and satisfying as the black box where we
shoot hot ones fire roasted habaneros
vinegar a touch of sea salt and olive
oil that's it
straight fire no fillers in the words of
trick trick welcome to Detroit City all
right governor what in the bloody hell
is this well I'm glad you asked in at
number seven this is Wilshire chili
farms Trinidad scorpion sauce it's the
first-ever sauce and hot ones from sunny
old England and at a hundred thousand
Scoville it's as scorching hot as a
hairy cane screamer from the top of the
18-yard box back of the net and oh dear
what do we have here
de bomb continues its run in the feared
number 8 slot to borrow a phrase from
Seth Rogen I would categorize this is
really hot and not just famous person
hot I'm already preparing my
inspirational speeches to keep guests
going on in the gauntlet and I just want
to issue a general apology to all the
publicists out there who have to deal
with the aftermath and speaking of
apologies I think the whole team owes me
an apology for cranking the number 9
slot even hotter than last season this
is the chocolate plague straight from
the diabolical mind of smokin ed curry
at pucker buck pepper company and the
Freak Show pepper this time around is
the chocolate boot la a mutant hybrid of
the ghost pepper and chocolate doula and
all right here we are rolling into the
last station closing it out the
signature last Avril ducks shakes its
way into season 9 thank you so much to
the fans out there who've now rocked
with us for three plus years eight plus
seasons and into season nine and
congratulations and welcome to the show
to all of our new hot sauce makers the
classic
the classic the last stab the last app
but welcome to the table Detroit
welcome to the table Shaquanda welcome
to the table Wilshire who appreciates
you baby
Tinashe where you at
[Music]
you
[Music]
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is Sean Evans checking in to say thank
you so much for watching today's episode
and I want to take a minute to open up
to everybody you know when I'm home
alone at night sitting in my love sack
thinking about what would make me happy
think about what would make my life
complete a beautiful healthy family a
french bulldog named sergeant biscuit a
lifetime supply of matcha lattes no none
of that it is 7 million YouTube
subscribers so if you haven't already
Ric Flair elbow drop that subscribe
button thank you for watching